[Música]
y en nuestra sección de economía hoy nos
acompaña Jorge Hurtado Jorge bienvenido
Qué tal María Clara un placer volver a
estar aquí con usted empecemos hablando
de Francia porque el gobierno hizo un
pacto con los supermercados para bajar
los precios durante tres meses en qué
consiste bueno La idea es dar los
precios más bajos posibles en una
selección de artículos que los
supermercados van a decidir para
enfrentar la inflación a partir de junio
los minoristas y el gobierno volverían a
evaluar la situación y podrían pedir a
los grandes proveedores de bienes de
consumo que renegocian estos precios con
los minoristas el anuncio lo dio a
conocer el ministro francés de economía
Bruno lemer que carrefour por ejemplo el
mayor minorista de alimentación de
Europa se adelantó a este anuncio
oficial del gobierno diciendo que
ofrecería su propia selección de 200
artículos de bajo costo y que no había
necesidad de que el gobierno impusiera
una cesta unificada casino su rival más
pequeño también anunció este lunes
ofrecerá su selección de 500 artículos
de bajo costo a menos de un euro a
partir del 15 de marzo pero esta
situación es para enfrentar la inflación
que el dato anual en Francia subió
inesperadamente el 7,2% en febrero desde
el 7 reportado en enero como
consecuencia de la subida de los precios
de los alimentos según las cifras
oficiales hay que ver también entonces
Jorge Cuáles son esos alimentos que van
a tener un precio más bajo y Esa no es
la única noticia de Francia porque se
esperan de nuevo huelgas masivas Este
martes bueno se espera solamente que uno
de cada cinco trenes regionales circule
el martes y un importante sindicalista
que representa a los trabajadores de las
refinerías prometió poner a la economía
francesa de rodillas Se esperan más de
260 manifestaciones en todo el país con
entre 1,1 y 1,4 millones de personas en
las calles los sectores marcharán
nuevamente en contra de este plan del
presidente macron de retrasar la edad de
jubilación a los 64 años el temor al
impacto de estas protestas hizo que
muchos franceses llenaran su tanque de
combustible por temor al
desabastecimiento que se podría provocar
por estas huelgas masivas escuchemos que
decían No no es fácil porque ya he ido a
dos gasolineras y ya no hay solo hay
diesel así que ya no hay 98 no hay nada
De hecho no queda nada
estamos preocupados Sí porque no sabemos
si va a ser la misma historia que la
última vez entre las huelgas y la
escasez de gasolina y diésel
Así que si vuelve a ocurrir sí causará
pánico y escasez Y por supuesto la gente
correrá a las gasolineras creo que va a
ser problemático
y mientras en Francia los sindicatos
quieren poner de rodillas al gobierno en
Reino Unido La idea es convertirse en
una superpotencia de ciencia y
tecnología así lo anunció el Primer
Ministro británico Richie suna que
también la titular de ciencia y
tecnología e Innovación Michel Donald en
el gobierno va a destinar allí 418
millones de euros en inversión para la
innovación que busca según ellos llevar
el mejor Talento del mundo a Reino Unido
y se aprovecharía el potencial de nuevas
tecnologías como la Inteligencia
artificial según el comunicado difundido
por down Street el plan Busca
inversiones públicas y privadas en
investigación y el desarrollo para
impulsar el crecimiento económico y una
mejor productividad en esa nación ahora
le propongo que nos vengamos de nuevo
América Latina porque la
superintendencia de transporte de
Colombia dijo que tomará el control o ya
lo tomó de la aerolínea divaer bueno el
gobierno colombiano pidió a la
superintendencia de sociedades que
acepte a la aerolínea en un proceso de
reorganización empresarial lo que le
permitiría congelar las deudas pasadas
para evitar de esta forma el quiebre de
la empresa se que 16.000 pasajeros
fueron afectados diariamente desde el
cese de operaciones el martes pasado
ahora será el estado colombiano quien
decida si viva sobrevivirá oirá a la
liquidación viva Air Dice que no puede
reembolsar un millón de tiquetes que no
se han utilizado y que tienen vigencia
hasta septiembre del 2024 al tiempo que
culpa de esta crisis aeronáutica civil
colombiana que en noviembre pasado
rechazó preliminarmente la integración
de esa compañía con la más grande de
Colombia que es Avianca Bueno un millón
de personas entonces que se quedan
afectadas por esto Jorge pasamos a
Nicaragua porque el gobierno Daniel
Ortega canceló la personería jurídica de
todas las cámaras empresariales Qué
significa Esto bueno se trata de 18
cámaras del sector privado más la de la
cúpula empresarial representada en el
consejo superior de la empresa privada
conocida allí como cosep el gobierno
Nicaragua argumenta que los empresarios
se incumplieron sus obligaciones
conforme a la ley ante la dirección
general de registro y control y
organismos de lucro y también ante el
Ministerio de gobernación pero la
cancelación de esas cámaras es el último
capítulo de este divorcio entre Daniel
Ortega y el gremio empresarial que
comenzó en abril de 2018 cuando
estallaron las protestas contra el
gobierno de Nicaragua que fueron
reprimidas con brutalidad en ese momento
el sector empresarial nicaragüense
condenó al gobierno y rompieron años de
relaciones que habían permitido al
sector privado prácticamente cogobernar
junto con Ortega desde su regreso al
poder en el año 2007 pues ya veremos
Entonces qué sucede con el sector
empresarial en Nicaragua Jorge Gracias
De nada nos vemos la próxima nos vemos
la próxima y nosotros continuamos con el
debate
[Música]